blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman all right so before uh i head out
on a brief break
i do want to touch on the fact that it
is august and that has some relevance
we're going to have some great guest
hosts coming up
fair and cousins will be filling in for
me jesse dollamore but
before i leave it is august and
supposedly donald trump is being
reinstated in august
um yesterday i spoke with my pillow guy
mike lindell who says
it'll be august maybe september it'll be
the supreme court probably but who knows
but to step step back for a second from
mike pillow
the real question many are asking is not
whether trump will be reinstated he
won't be reinstated
but whether his followers will become
violent when he doesn't get reinstated
and whether his followers will try to
stage a second insurrection
now yesterday we looked at clips of an
organization that says they're going
back to the capitol on september 18th
there are i think we can say
conservatively
millions of people like maybe it's not
tens of millions but it's certainly
millions of people followers of trump
who have been led to believe by any
number of others that donald trump will
be returning to the throne as it were
somehow this month or next month it
might be
through the supreme court it might be
through the generals of the military
doing something nebulous that we don't
understand
or it'll be because something
incriminating will come out and joe
biden will resign and so will kamala
harris which by the way wouldn't make
trump
president right i mean trump is not part
of the line of succession right now
or maybe they don't even know how it's
going to happen but they think maybe it
will
but it won't be happening and so then
what among the 50-plus
attendees that salon spoke with at cpac
in dallas
more than 40 percent said they believed
in august trump would be reinstated
somehow
what do they do when it doesn't happen
some law enforcement agencies are paying
attention
zachary patrizo writes in salon that
quote on july 13
bloomberg news reported that lindell's
theories are enough to put fbi director
christopher wray
and other top national security
officials on alert
for the risk that the former president's
most ardent supporters
might again resort to violence now we're
already seeing dates
move around what was once august 13th
now some people say will be august 21st
why well august 21st trump will be
speaking at a rally in
coleman alabama one rumor
of new i guess you could call it a new
delusion is that trump will be
reinstated at that rally by who how it's
not exactly clear because it will never
happen
and the shifting of the date is very
much like the end of the world rapture
people i've interviewed some of these
people
there's always some date it doesn't
happen so they shift the date they say
oh we misread the signals or
god changed his mind or something was
out of context and then they come up
with a new date
i don't know that it will prevent the
violence
but it needs to be somehow put in these
people's minds that
trump just lost it's an occam's razor
the simplest explanation
is the one that applies the election was
certified
joe biden was the winner and he was
sworn in donald trump is not in the line
of succession
if the president goes then it goes to
the vp and if the vp goes bye-bye then
it's the speaker of the house and so on
trump is not part of that the last
president is not part of that
uh and some others are saying now very
directly
as i told you yesterday that it will be
september and they're going to the
capitol
so i think the risk for violence is real
for me is trump really getting
reinstated is not the right question
it's it's a silly question of course
he's not the real question
is will there be violence and i'm
worried that there will be
we'll pick up on that much more in
future shows and
let's hope it doesn't happen you know
for a little while it was
mostly a radical republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
who was comparing things to the
holocaust equating things to the nazis
raising other comparisons to world war
ii it's now just becoming very
widespread on the american right and it
has a lot to do with vaccines we're
going to look at a few clips
here is david brody who used to be a
regular panelist on meet the press
he was on his show i guess he has a show
now water cooler on real america's voice
i don't know i don't even know what that
means
he is again talking about nazis and
nuremberg
codes when it comes to vaccination take
a listen violation
of federal law so why well because it
would violate a little thing called the
nuremberg code
code mentioned on the fda website not
pizzagate.com
or conspiracy.net the nuremberg code
emphasizes that people cannot be forced
to take experimental drugs
without their full consent now interest
interestingly here
the term nuremberg code originated in
1947 germany during the nuremberg trials
where of course
nazi doctors attempted to excuse the
inhumane deadly experiments that they
conducted on concentration camp
prisoners
by claiming that there were no explicit
rules governing medical research on
human beings in germany
during that period but you're probably
thinking well hey hold on that's nazi
germany
and not the us nurburgring would never
admit yeah
so so the implication is that having a
requirement in order to work at certain
places
or go to certain schools or whatever the
case may be that that's equival
of a phase three trial uh faith widely
phased three child
uh vaccine is similar to nazi medical
experimentation
on jews now that sounds sort of crazy
because it is
so then when he brings on his guest matt
staver
he sort of says you know we're not
literally saying that but
so you kind of are dude take a listen
well you know it's interesting you say
the sirens should go off
and you're absolutely right
unfortunately the sirens are going off
the other way the vaccinated
or excuse me the unvaccinated in this
country are being demonized uh
there's discriminatory stuff going on
out there i i'm curious as it relates to
the legal issues here regarding the
nuremberg code i mean if it's under
experimental use
uh what what does that mean legally in
terms of now even that
when they say what e it just so happens
that experiment
and emergency both start with the letter
e
and eua is an emergency use
authorization it's not an experimental
use
authorization that's that's another
deliberate deception of this going up
the uh
legal food chain what what could happen
here
well even before you get to the
nuremberg code you have the emergency
use authorization line it clearly says
that
you have the quote option to accept or
refuse close
quote that's repeated in the fact sheet
required by the fda and it's also
mentioned many times by the fda so
that's the end of story you have the
option to refuse
when it's in the eua and it's an eoa
specifically designated so by the fda
now do you guys believe that when you
know we're somewhere between two and
five weeks from at least the pfizer
vaccine
given given permanent approval by the
fda
do you think that when that happens
they'll just say oh now we're good now
go and get vaccinated of course not
they're just going to come up with
something else
and federal law in the nuremberg code
the very first point says
that the voluntary consent of the human
subject is absolutely
essential there should be no duress no
deception
no pressure and we're doing exactly the
opposite
we are violating federal law we're
violating the nuremberg code all of
these will be brought into court
to raise these issues because we are
repeating this is the tragic part of
this we're repeating the dark history
of nazi germany and we're not learning
the lessons that the nuremberg
you know we're really not matt code and
those nazi experiments
should have taught this generation so
you're you're liking it to that time
period we talked about that in the
monologue and we want to be clear i
guess we have to do the disclaimer about
the holocaust and jews we're not talking
about
that right i begrudgingly have to
mention we're not really talking about
the holocaust
except we are because we're saying that
a required vaccine
after phase three trials uh violates the
nuremberg codes
just like the nazis did during their
medical experiments it's crazy
this is where they're now uh this is the
plane where they now exist
here's one more example newsmax guest
pastor brian gibson
yeah says that vaccination you just won
the election
that was actually an accident uh newsmax
guest uh pastor brian gibson says
vaccination
is going to provide a framework for
future genocide yeah
what do you make of that pastor yeah
yeah
they're playing uh this comes straight
out of the marxist handbook
right you try to set as many different
groups against each other
as you can in a nation to weaken it tear
it apart and rebuild it in the image you
want
uh at first in america it was it was
racial tension black versus white
now we're moving from vaccinated to the
unvaccinated
and i'll tell you it's scary because
whenever you see
guys saying you see leaders saying you
can go to the gym if you have the
vaccination
you see the president talking about the
problem that is the
unvaccinated these things have played
out before
in history he's sort of alluding to
saying the unvaccinated in a pejorative
way
is like when the nazis started saying
the jews
he that if you're not making the
connection this is the analogy he's
making and then he actually just
straight up says it where do you take a
certain group of people and demonize
them yeah and i'll tell you what it is
it's a framework
for animosity between two groups at best
at worst it's a framework for a future
genocide so there it is
just like the jews started to be
demonized
by the nazis the unvaccinated or
starting to be demonized by the
vaccinated i guess and by joe biden
uh that we we are in real real serious
trouble here as a country my friends if
these narratives become the prevailing
narrative so
once we get that fda approval let's see
how many of them go out and get
vaccinated it won't be quote
experimental anymore as they like to say
let's see how many of them go out and
get vaccinated at that point in time let
me know your thoughts uh on twitter you
can find me at deepakman
and remember that we are now just about
10 days away
from the david pakman show 16th
anniversary on that day
august 16th you can get an insanely
discounted david pakman show membership
i would love for you to do that and
support the program if you want to be
notified on august 16th of how to do
that
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is
only about eight bucks a month and you
get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
all right let's hear from some people in
the audience because
we're doing this a little bit early this
week i've got some travel coming up
we've got some
great guest hosts instead of the show
going dark
uh we will have farron cousins doing a
little bit of guest hosting
and jesse dollamore doing a little bit
of guest hosting it's going to be super
strong and i'm very much looking forward
to it but first
let's talk to some of you we do this now
via discord
you can find our discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go next
to andrew from new york and we're from
new york
yeah i knew it wasn't on my end yeah
andrew what's going on now now you do
have me on some kind of speaker in the
background it sounds like
oh yeah i'm sorry uh this is the best
mic i've got but um
i'll make it quick and easy please
what a what is your uh opinion on um
uh uh um
the new um the new the
uh the um the new mass laws
uh uh well i have a better one um how
about uh
cuba what is your opinion on the embargo
of the embargo that's going on in cuba
that the
and buying supporting the um the uh
the protesters uh that's a better
question i am against the embargo
i support the protesters
all right um let's all right
all right thanks andrew very much
appreciate that let's go next to chris
from maine
chris you were on the air in maine
just barely it sounds like you're
talking through some kind of metal sieve
okay hang on sorry about that
just just barely just barely it's what
what kind of a device are you using i
have to ask
wow all right i'm gonna let you go i
appreciate the call very much
let's go next to sam from new york city
on what is not an auspicious
start here sam from new york city you're
on the air
yeah can you hear me i'll try to help
turn things around yeah please
i can hear you fine all right i'll try
my best
one question that i've grappled with
really for since i guess
you know trump came down the escalator
or you know that moment
is you know i i know you don't identify
as a
you're not a registered democrat correct
that's right
but you tend to align with it i am a
registered democrat but also like you
have my issues with the party
one thing i try to ask myself is
what would it take for me to vote
for a republican you know
when i consider how insane
decision must be to vote for donald
trump i think i cannot imagine how
anyone would
logically come to that conclusion one
thing i try to ask myself is hmm all
right well
what would a democrat do that would make
me not support a democrat and
is there a line you think i'm not being
super clear but i guess
should we see more understanding of
potential reasons
diehard republicans voted for trump when
his democrats are incredibly unwilling
to consider voting more republican well
you've got to talk to the democrats that
you're referring to and see what their
answer would be like for me it's really
clear
if you give me a race where the
republican
is the better option than the democrat
based on policy and based on all of the
things that we look at
like in other words if in the last
election joe biden
was the republican and trump was the
democrat i would have voted for the
republican joe biden because i thought
joe biden was the better option what
you're i think getting to is people who
are
blindly voting for party without really
looking at the candidates right
yeah i guess it's also a moral question
let's say
the republican and democrat are both
sort of generic
middle road republicans democrats in
terms of policy but the democrat is
incredibly compromised
um or you know some personal behavior or
whatever else
sure yeah i mean that's one
consideration the other consideration
could be
you might have a very centrist democrat
and a very centrist republican
and they are very similar on policy but
you might say well overall
the platform of the democratic party is
closer to my view than the platform of
the republican party
so even though i'm kind of indifferent
on these two candidates i'll vote for
the democrat because
their party has the platform i prefer
this is
uh unfortunately this is way more
thought than most people put into who
they vote for
i mean i i hate to say but it's sort of
like i believe that just take health
care policy by the democrats yeah saves
many thousands of can has the potential
to save thousands of american lives so
even if some
democrat is obviously hypothetical went
out and killed someone
you know they killed one person but i
think electing them would pass
health care policy that would save
thousands of lives then you can sort of
make
a calculation that utilitarian
calculations justify it no
no yeah no that makes sense i mean
that's sort of like if you have two
candidates one of whom
is a rapist but would likely pass
medicare for all
does it still make sense to vote for the
rapist because it's going to be good for
so many people i mean yeah you start to
get into those types of questions and
it's a very personal thing for a lot of
people
yeah well thank you for your
thoughtfulness on this appreciate the
call thank you very much
uh very important topic let's go next
to nary from boston nary
you are on the air hey david
jumped into you a few months ago but i
was
curious on one of your and this has been
a couple weeks now around mike pence
uh-huh do you think trump could
kind of save him from the grave he put
him in
and taking him back as the vp like hey
he betrayed us but i talked to him
he's on our side now he'll do what he'll
do
absolutely tru you can all in politics
you can
almost always rescue whoever even though
mike pence has been vilified you know
they were chanting hang
pens he spoke at some conservative
conference a couple weeks ago the whole
crowd booed him i think that's what
you're referring to
trump has said things about mike pence
let us down if in
just hypothetically if in 2024
trump ran and he said we are bringing
back
the best vice president this country has
ever had
he did what he could with the election
but we just didn't have the rhinos with
us
he could completely come up with some bs
and say pence is the greatest and
rehabilitate his
reputation overnight
i was stuck between like should he try
to grab pence or be like
okay ron desentes yeah
ever even though i hate you because
you're
the second yeah i have no i i think that
it's too early to tell trump could go
either way
um you know the thing about trump is
even if he assesses he has a better shot
at winning with
desantis trump wants to definitely be
like the alpha as he sees it
and mike pence has much more sort of
like
stereotypical beta vibes than ron
desantis i mean this is like such stupid
language
i don't even know that this really
exists but the way they see it
i think desantis is not as good of a
beta to trump's alpha
as is mike pence now there's nothing
actually alpha about trump but i'm just
saying as they see it
makes sense yeah all right my friend
thank you for the call
all right there's nary from boston
let's go uh next
to oh i don't know let's i'm told that
tristan from kansas city is back on
tristan
i hope your mic's working hey there you
are
hi david so as you know i'm i'm a
recovering
you know not recovered but i used to be
a conspiracy theorist back in like
2016. and uh of course there's no
shortage of conspiracy theorists now
in fact it's probably worse than it's
ever been but uh there there is some
videos that i keep getting sent
and i'm i'm wondering if you know
anything about the great reset because i
would like a rational take on it because
i saw the video by the world economic
forum and it is very
uh dystopian looking to say the least
so do you know anything about that i
mean it correct me if i'm wrong the
great reset is the idea
that on some kind of cyclical calendar
there are events that sort of like call
the weak
and reduce the population and create
kind of like the idea of
resetting and uh restarting
more strongly and that there's gonna
have to be some bad things that happen
and so getting to that point including
death and destruction
but then you reset and then you build
better in a way is that generally
the great reset idea uh yeah
and of course everybody's taking that
because it is you know it's
it's a very challenging idea and of
course people are saying oh that's the
new world order that they're talking
about
and to quote one of the comments what i
see it as a psychotic billionaire is
telling everyone how bad billionaires
are
and they're the ones who are going to
fix it yeah i mean listen here's the
thing every once in a while this is the
problem with sophistry and
pseudo-intellectualism
that every once in a while some idea
that people who don't read history or
philosophy or political science or
whatever
they have no frame of reference so they
hear like some hypothesis like this
and then all of a sudden they're like
wow this is the ex this is like some
grand theory that explains everything
and they become very emotionally
attached to it whereas like a lot of
people who do more
reading and studying would be like no
one thing is the full explanation to
everything you know you read
you have to read a lot of different
things and there's aspects that make
sense from from each thing
this is kind of like the problem with
pseudo and anti-intellectualism that for
people who have no frame of reference
they hear
one type of idea one time and they
become very attached to it right away
and then you can't even have normal
conversations with them so i i don't
know that i have that much more to say
about it
other than i don't think any one idea
explains the world
in total and we should be very skeptical
of anybody who points to this is the
explanation for why things are the way
they are of course
yeah i think epistemology is the right
word for it sure yeah i mean
understanding
where are why we believe the things we
believe yeah
of course all right well your comment
section
in this clip is probably going to be
pretty toxic just a fair warning but
thank you david okay all right thanks
very much there's tristan from
kansas city missouri we are taking calls
uh a day early because we i'm going to
be traveling and a lot of different
you know things are going on and it's
all crazy let's go
uh next to chris from maine who says
that he has fixed his microphone as well
hello
can you hear me yes i can chris okay
uh i have a question for you what do you
think will happen
when um trump will not get reinstated
in in august which it now is
yes what what do you think that
mike lindell and the trumpist will do um
i think that
a few of them will try to get some kind
of violent thing going
they may succeed or they may not most of
them will do nothing
and many will become fixated on some new
date at which something is supposedly
going to happen
okay and uh one more question for you
yeah what do you think
what do you think would happen if trump
ran in 2024 and then had
ron desantis as a as his running mate
yeah i mean i i think that that would
pro
right now i would say that gives him a
better shot than running alongside mike
pence but as i mentioned to the caller
earlier i don't know that trump's ego
lets him have someone like desantis
who's much less of a second
fiddle the way mike mike pence was
basically a plant
sometimes he it was almost like is is
that a lemon tree or is that
mike pence in the background there um
and ron desantis isn't like that
and trump needs a real um beta to use
their word behind him so
that's what makes me doubt trump would
pick desantis as his running mate
okay thank you i'm curious how old a guy
are you
i am i am 15. i thought so okay that's
that's
it's great that you're uh get following
what's going on in the world i i think
that that's a really great thing chris
yeah thank you all right there's chris
from maine the most coherent caller of
the day and only 15 years old if you can
believe it
um just so people know everybody who's
waiting to get on
and all that shows up is like a nickname
you're not getting on so if you want if
you want a chance at talking to me
it has to say name and town okay so
there's a lot of nicknames
there's zero chance you're getting on if
that's what you have let's go next to
vihan from orlando florida did i
pronounce that correctly
yeah can you hear me david i can hear
you fine vihan
all right so i was just uh wanting to
ask a question about the infrastructure
bill please
because we have the bipartisan one that
has 17 gop
senators and is very likely to pass but
i'm concerned about the
reconciliation package and um
senator manchin has said that there's no
chance it's
uh there's no guarantee it's going to
pass
right and senator cinema has said that
she's not going to
uh cancel her vacation plans uh to vote
on this um
package which i object to but it is what
it is do you think the reconciliation
package
has um any realistic chance of passing
in the law
i have no idea and i see really no
i mean we'll know soon at this point
this type of prediction to me is not
super interesting like
maybe you know what i i don't really
know i i think the more important thing
on this issue is the entire framing of
this infrastructure thing as
oh how do we pay for it can we afford it
what really counts as infrastructure if
if people so there's progressives who
want to do infrastructure
for its economic stimulus and so on and
so forth
every right winger who is of the mindset
of usa number one
should be begging for this
infrastructure package because
you look around the world and you look
at american public transit it's a joke
you look around the world and you look
at our top airports
they're a joke you look around the world
at broadband access and then you see the
united states
it's a joke forget about you know
bridges and tunnels of course
if you are an america first america
needs to be the best thing
how on earth do you justify not doing
this infrastructure
deal it's at the the terms on which it's
being discussed are crazy
left and right should be completely
united on this and getting this done
could be for different reasons who cares
um and the entire you know i'm sick of
the joe mansion and cinema stuff
i'm sick of the republicans who are just
like oh we don't have money we don't
have money
hold on a second this is first of all we
do have the money
secondly it's so economically
stimulative to do this type of sp
it's just crazy so to answer your
question which i'm not really answering
i have no idea in hell whether the
reconciliation version has a chance of
passing
but these people better pass something
because the country is desperately in
need of it
yeah yeah that's uh that's totally
correct and we badly need that
infrastructure package thank you for
taking my call david
my pleasure really great hearing from
you i'm going to take some more calls
but in a moment i'm going to take a very
quick break
just hold on and then i'll be right back
with everybody
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
let's go back to the phones which are no
longer phones
we are in the 21st century and we take
our calls via discord you can find the
discord at davidpakman.com
discord just a reminder if you want to
get on
uh in the in the waiting lobby it should
have your name
and where you were calling from very
very important let's go
overseas and go to diego from the united
kingdom you were on the air
diego sorry i i i thought i wouldn't
have any problems with my mic but i did
uh hello david i just wanted to ask you
about um in the theme of misinformation
and conspiracies
yes a lot of people have talked about
for example nationalizing
uh socializing google as a way of
protecting the
public sphere um i know for example
andrew yang talked about
creating data dividend do you what do
you think about these kind of measures
uh as a way of kind of combating
misinformation yeah do you have any
different
proposals that would be interesting you
are not going to solve this issue
by nationalizing a publicly traded
company like
google i mean listen if if google were
on the verge of failing
and the government bailed them out they
might have
some leverage to ask for something but
this is where i feel like guys what are
we talking about
nationalizing google if we want to deal
with disinformation
if we want to deal with you know the
online
bullying and calls to violence and all
we've got to have companies that have
clear terms of service
and they enforce them fairly and equally
we need proper if if you want to look at
antitrust okay look at
actually dealing with antitrust and
enforce it fairly you've got all these
republicans who haven't
given two you-know-whats about antitrust
and monopolies for 40 years
and now they only want to apply existing
uh
in antitrust law to social media
companies
hey listen if you want to do that i'm
i'm open to doing that but you've got to
enforce it
seriously across industry in in other
places
and we've got to deal with education so
that people are less susceptible
to the disinformation and the nonsense
to begin with but this is where like
nash you're not you're just not going to
nationalize google it's not it's just
not going to happen
and so i worry that people get sucked
down like oh that sounds appealing
it's just not happening there's no
there's no legal basis for it
there's no political will for it it just
you know we've got so many other things
we can do
yeah i would tend to agree with that
absolutely um
could i ask you about um your thoughts
on um
wealth tax i know i'm being a little bit
cheeky asking you two questions
no i mean listen i think uh i i think
wealth tax
is an interesting idea the point of the
what so
what's the problem with income taxes and
capital gains taxes the problem is that
there's ways to avoid them and have
significant growth
of wealth without
any of that growth being captured by the
government so the idea is you
you put in a wealth tax i am really
skeptical about how you enforce it
you could have situations where people
in order to make their wealth tax
payments actually have to
sell assets and realize gains now some
might say that's the point get them to
realize the gains
um i i see it very logistically
problematic but i think
the impetus for capturing wealth growth
that really rich people keep outside of
income
it's a smart idea it's a sensible idea i
just don't know how you actually
get it done okay that's very interesting
and finally i just wanted to say that um
a long time ago you talked to someone
from argentina about empanadas
yes and i just wanted to um put the
chilean perspective and say that uh
chilean empanadas are very good i
haven't tried the argentinians so i
can't say they're better
right they are very good are chilean
empanadas typically baked or fried
uh it depends so the the the baked ones
are the meat
ones and the fried ones would be cheese
or uh seafood ones
i just can't get behind a fried empanada
i have to tell you that's one of the
things that is that is
typical of the argentinian empanada i
want it oven
baked i don't want it deep fried i want
to taste the filling
not the oil it was fried in you
understand
i can i can be i can be in support of
that yeah the empanadas
are baked so i'm sure you'd enjoy one if
you tried one all right sounds fantastic
i appreciate the call
thank you all right there we go there's
diego from the uk
super strong phone call let's go next to
brandon from colorado
brandon you are on the air hi david can
you hear me i can hear you perfectly
great so my mom is heavily invested into
the anti-vaxx
uh scene and i'm sent a lot of videos
all the time yep and i've been watching
them
and clearly there's another ground uh of
anti-vax
communities and they do not agree on
facts
and they're sort of trapped in their
echo chamber they think what they're
doing is right and so on
and i do not think that
the uh covid conferences like we heard
this week
um are not really going to cut it for
these people who are
um spreading this information and so i'm
thinking what i would be interested to
see
would be uh the people that they think
are lying
so medical experts doctors whatever uh
personally confront them to show them
the evidence
and hopefully talk through with them to
come to a realization of the truth
to actually get on the page with the
facts and i'm wondering
do you think this would even be possible
or people are
considering this uh could this be a
valid tactic to at least
engage with this uh very serious part of
uh anti-vaccine misinformation so first
of all i mean on a very practical level
there's not enough doctors and public
health experts to do one-on-one
confrontations with anti-vaxxers to
convince them to change their mind so so
on a practical level i think it's very
difficult the other thing is
often times when people are presented
with facts and told what you believe is
wrong here are the facts
it doesn't convince them it actually
makes them further
kind of plant their feet in the sand and
not move from where they are
what we do know is that the people
that are already in one's community so
if dr
fauci shows up at your mom's house
she'll probably be like this guy's a
liar i over this
i'm not gonna believe this guy but if
your mom's doctor
who presumably she trusts says you need
to get the vaccine it's really important
i've gotten it my patient
that does seem to have a real impact so
i think it's less about bringing in
experts from outside people's lives to
tell them you're wrong
it's more about creating conversations
with the people already in your
community so for some people
it's it's their pastor which is so
disturbing why when we see these pastors
like greg locke who we covered earlier
this week say do not get vaccinated to
their churches
a lot of people if their pastor said get
vaccinated they would do it
same thing goes for local physicians and
uh that type of thing so
i think that there's a lot to what
you're saying in terms of people need to
hear from their local doctor whoever
people they trust go and get vaccinated
if you sit dr fauci in front of your mom
i don't think it convinces her
do you think that would be sort of the
same case because what i'm saying is
to uh to to confront like the host of
these
shows on bit shoot or whatever who have
had their shows for so long
basically it's sort of the same thought
as uh what did you say
[ __ ] [ __ ] what what was that uh bit
shoot
[ __ ] okay uh uh tum rumble
you know those underground youtube cases
i mean
but i i mean basically the same ideas
what if we got the biggest
uh you know flat earth personalities
oh i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying so if there's some really
big anti-vaxx
person with a big audience and they get
just schooled and made to look like
idiots but
yeah that could have an impact that
could have an impact that i don't deny
that that's an interesting idea
okay well thank you for uh free call
thank you all right brandon from
colorado uh i will call you again
soon let's go next
where are we going next there it's just
crazy what's happening
let's go to giovanni from santa clarita
giovanni are on the air
giovanni you're on the air
well no jovani that's too bad
let's try um let's try
jamie jamie from i can't tell where
jamie uh hello hello
uh hi david hi
um i had a question about uh well i was
gonna say i started watching your videos
um
like during the pandemic when i had
online school and stuff
okay and you really helped me out thank
you um
but uh i had a question about like the
i know you're focused on like 2022 but
uh like 2024 is kind of scaring me
yeah like if uh i don't know all the
republicans just kind of like seem like
the same
like policy-wise so like i don't know
uh can you even tell i mean most of them
most of them don't even
most of them don't even talk about
policy so i don't know how you can even
tell
right right that's the part that really
scares me yeah
yeah yeah so i mean did you have a
question about that
oh i had like what uh what republican
do you think would like do like the
least damage
like if they got voted in i mean i think
somebody
uh like mitt romney maybe you know it's
like some people are talking about liz
cheney
i think liz cheney is actually more more
dangerous she's really
she's more of a war hawk than romney
right she agrees with trump
yeah pretty much all the time 90 93 of
the time whereas romney is more like in
the 80s
i mean i think the the thing of i'm sure
there's other people who are moderate
republicans as well but in terms of like
prominent people
the thing about romney is um
i think that on social stuff he's more
or less indifferent from a policy
standpoint i know as a mormon he
probably has views i disagree with but i
don't think he would like prosecute too
much social stuff
he might try on abortion but i feel like
almost that that's pretty far gone i
think
it would be tough to do that he doesn't
strike me as the guy who would try to
start
global conflicts although i know there's
examples of him saying hawkish things
and so basically it would be like can we
keep romney in the middle
rather than going to the right on you
know business regulation
and taxation and stuff like that like
it's not i'm not saying i'd go and vote
for romney but if you said what
prominent republican would if it has to
be one would i go with
it would be somebody like romney
probably
okay yeah thank you for answering my
question david my pleasure
thank you for the call i appreciate that
what a polite caller i love that
um okay let's talk to a couple of other
people because it is
it's really quite a quite a special day
let's go to
victor from california victor you're on
the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
i um just want to kind of go over and
ask what you thought about this idea of
fake news do you think that
um kind of and by the way i'm a big fan
of your show and other kind of
commentary shows
thank you youtube but do you think what
we're doing
or what um kind of this move towards
hard news towards more commentating
um news is kind of uh creating more of
this
cloud of fake news in the world
i don't think i you said the move
towards hard news and commentating news
those are two different
yes right so right now when you look at
the media for example if you go to
fox news or you go to cnn a lot of it is
is kind of news interwoven with
commentary yeah so they'll report on a
fact the report on an event that
actually is happening for example if
like say a president is proposing some
new legislation or he's
signing in to lost something yeah
they'll report that event and then
they'll make some kind of commentary on
it right and
if i'm a viewer watching this what i'm
already doing is i'm already kind of
um looking at what uh listening to
what's happening
and getting a kind of subjective
experience sure right so if i'm a
conservative and i watch
fox news or cnn for example
and there's some news that's being
reported on and then there's comment
commentat uh some kind of commentary
that i don't agree with
i'll just automatically assume that it's
fake news and the same goes with like a
liberal watching fox news
and so yeah that's moving towards
uh the hard news to more kind of
commentary and punditry both from the
left and right kind of increases this
world of not only echo chambers but uh
this idea of fake news so your questions
your question is kind of complicated and
i only sort of understand it but let me
tell you a couple different things
one um a lot of people if it
if it's packaged like a news show they
think it's just news
right so you look at fox in the morning
and then you see tucker carlson
at night and it looks pretty damn
similar so you're like this is all news
when it's it's really not
the other problem is there will be
commentary even in shows that are
supposed to be just news shows
that's that's another issue and a lot of
people aren't able to sort of suss that
out
and then the same applies to online
stuff you look at websites for fake
news news sites and real news and they
look almost identical
people can't tell the difference so i
don't know that the problem is
necessarily
that you're seeing the mix of news and
opinion
although you can argue that that is part
of the problem because of how ignorant
people are
but really the problem is the lack of
media literacy and the lack of people
who can think
critically about what they're watching
yeah do you think though
it's like they're just naive or do you
think that um
like if we define truth as something
that could be possibly subjective
for example if uh um if there's a law
that
uh comes into play that lowers taxes for
example and i'm a conservative and i
believe that lowering taxes
helps stimulate the economy or am i i'm
a liberal that thinks that lowering
taxes hurts infrastructure for example
do you think that if i'm watching like a
news segment on cnn or fox news
then i'm going to agree or disagree
depending on my already preconceived
notions of this
yeah that's called confirmation bias
widely
do you think that's kind of contributing
to this idea of fake news
or is it if it was just hard facts if it
was just i'm sorry if it was just hard
news
all the time we would kind of just like
absorb the news and make that opinion
you know on our in our day-to-day
political lives whereas yeah
maybe i mean you know it's very
theoretical and it's just not the
situation that we have
i do think the other problem is that
fake news is be so
opinions disguised as news are different
than fake news
fake news is a very specific thing it's
now being applied too broadly
what you're saying is blurring the lines
between opinion
and news reporting and that's that's
different than fake news but i think
there's probably more to say but but i
think you know i've kind of given you my
general sense of it
well i appreciate it thank you very much
all right there's victor from california
very much appreciate the call
let's go to a break i'm sorry i couldn't
speak to more people today but i will
speak to more people very soon that's
for sure
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
pakman show where you can get access to
behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
alright let's get into audience
questions for the week one day early
because of my upcoming trip remember
we're going to have some great guest
hosts upcoming including
farron cousins from ring of fire and
fair and balance the eponymously named
fair and balanced
um also jesse dolimore it's going to be
great it's going to be absolutely
fantastic but let's get right into your
questions
david do you think joe biden is really
going to try to pass a national vaccine
mandate
the statements so far from the white
house have been confusing yeah so
the white house i think is being careful
there's been a couple of times now where
white house
staffers have been asked about is by
investigating is biden planning for is
he getting
advice about a possible vaccine mandate
and the answer has been
pretty carefully worded that is not
something he
is looking to do or has any plans to do
at this time
and of course when i hear that i don't
hear
he's eventually going to do it i hear
he's not ruling it out unconditionally
because circumstances may change and
it's conceivable that it makes sense to
leave it on the table but i actually
don't think
the biden administration is going to
even attempt to pass
a federal vaccine mandate um however
we've already talked about the potential
legality
of state-level vaccine mandates and
municipality level vaccine mandates and
there does seem to be precedent for it
you look at
cambridge massachusetts in the very
early 20th century i don't remember if
it was 1905
1903 there was a point where the the
city of cambridge
said you must be vaccinated against
smallpox
the vaccine was quote experimental at
the time much the same way that now
the vaccines have not yet received fda
approval although
they're expected too soon and so my
guess would be that if joe biden
wanted to try to force
people to be vaccinated and again that
doesn't mean someone shows up and holds
you down
my guess is that it would be some kind
of requirement with
i don't know maybe a fine attached to it
or something even saying it doesn't
really make any sense because i don't
think it's going to happen i think the
way biden would do it
is he would push for governors
or municipalities to mandate it
which seems much more
um based in precedent at least from a
legal standpoint now i'll i'll go even
further
i don't know that we're really going to
see that because i
i think accurately it's seen as likely
political suicide for whoever tries to
do it
i think even in blue states with
democratic governors
a vaccine mandate could be a recipe for
you lose your next re-election because
i think it would not be well received by
enough people
in basically every state that it could
be a
really politically disastrous thing to
do and so
more plausible and maybe equally
effective
is just look at the polling where people
say
what would be most likely to encourage
them to get vaccinated so as an example
last week i covered this live event
where joe biden said
hey governors please use the money we
sent you
to give a hundred dollars to everybody
who goes and gets a first shot
okay a poll was done on that over the
weekend
and only 14 of americans who are not
interested in the vaccine
said a hundred dollars would change
their mind 14 said
i don't want the vaccine but for a
hundred bucks i would go
contrast that with 41
of those who don't currently want a
vaccine who said if it was required to
fly
i would go and get vaccinated it doesn't
take
that much thinking to realize joe biden
and the federal government through the
faa
uh have a lot of say over what happens
on airplanes
and would there be a more effective
approach than mandating vaccines or
giving people 100 bucks
then working through the faa either to
directly
or to encourage airlines to say you must
be vaccinated in order to fly with us or
at minimum if you're not vaccinated you
have to
do a negative test uh you could even i
think even
that would significantly increase
vaccination numbers right now when you
fly domestically there might be some
examples like i know at one point hawaii
was doing something
with testing right now though to fly
domestically you don't even need to be
tested
so you could even stop short of a
vaccine requirement for for aviation
domestic aviation you could just say
you now have two options when you fly
you either bring proof of vaccination
uh which i know some people will say
well people will start faking those
that's got to be punished really
seriously really really seriously the
way canada punished a couple of
americans for faking
vaccine information um you either give
us proof of vaccination
or you've got to get a test right here
uh or within 48 72 however you figure it
out
that would make a really big dent in
those who don't want to get vaccinated
go by what people are telling you is the
point that i'm trying to make
i don't expect joe biden to actually try
a federal
vaccine mandate i think if he wants to
go in that direction it's likely he
would say
governors please do this in your states
of course if he did that
the governors that are willing to do it
are probably the ones in the states that
are already more vaccinated and less
urgently would need to do it that's
always that's sort of a moral hazard
status quo type of thing but that's the
way i see it let me know if you see the
likelihood
of a biden vaccine mandate differently
david even though ron desantis has made
florida into covet hell could it somehow
help him politically including maybe
when he runs or if he runs in 2024.
yeah i i talked about this a little bit
on monday
if you just think logically
you would look at what's happening in
florida record cases
record hospitalization relatively
low vaccination rate um and ron desantis
going around saying
we're banning mask mandates we're not
going to make kids in school wear masks
open everything no limits on any okay
you would see that and you would say
this is going to backfire this is going
to be
terrible for ron desantis i don't really
know about that
because if thinking ahead if ron
desantis chooses to challenge
trump in 24 or trump doesn't even run
and ron desantis does
you already know know or can predict the
way that ron desantis's
handling of covet is going to be done in
terms of a revisionist history
ron desantis ron desantis will say
i was the freedom person we dealt with
covid but we did it with
freedom and we allowed people to decide
for themselves what they want no nanny
state and republicans around him will
probably cheer it on and say that's
exactly what he did so
while you and i i mean it's sort of like
the trump coveted reaction
now you listen to trump's former press
secretary
kelly mcinanny and other people that
work for trump they talk about trump's
handling of covet as if it was great it
was one of the worst in the world
and they've rewritten history to say it
was great it was absolutely fantastic
so while it should hurt ron desantis how
disastrously he has made florida
into covet hell central over the last
month or two
um it will almost certainly be reframed
so that the right will only talk about
the good things
we supported business and business
owners
by opening businesses and letting
business owners
and people decide what they feel safe
doing that's the way it should be
we don't want the government in your bus
i know that you're saying david that you
sound insane when you say that yeah i'm
telling you what they will say
and it is insane but if we've learned
anything over the last few years
it's that these people will fall for
insane narratives these people will fall
for absolutely false
uh stories about what's going on in the
world so
i wouldn't say ron desantis destroying
florida
is going to be helpful to him but i do
think
that his destroying florida can be
rewritten
into a story about freedom and being
about letting business owners run
businesses
that might end it make it might end up
making it sort of like a break even for
ron desantis if you were to run in 2024
or even in terms of just re-election for
the florida governorship
if you disagree with me definitely let
me let me know
david i'm starting to see headlines that
joe biden's approval rating is
collapsing is this true so first let's
answer
the question about the approval rating
then let's talk about what's actually
going on
if you look at 538 joe biden's approval
has only dropped like within the margin
of error when i looked uh most recently
joe biden's approval on an average of
approval ratings went from 53 to 51.5
that's a really really small change to
say it's statistically significant
yet but let's imagine
that it's true that joe biden's approval
is declining a little bit
i think there there's uh a couple things
to think about
first of all it might be more important
to look at disapproval than approval
on disapproval joe biden's disapproval
has gone up from an average of 36 to an
average of 43.
my guess is that that's right wingers
who have shifted
from having no real opinion to saying
they don't like what joe biden is doing
probably in part because of the
propaganda particularly around
vaccines and coveted masks that has been
spreading
among right-wing media circles but i
think in this case it's a little more
important to zoom out
it's very common that a normal president
not trump
a normal president comes in with a
relatively high or higher approval
rating
and then over time their approval
begins to erode and their disapproval
starts to go up
why is this a lot of this approval
disapproval stuff
is based on has the president done
anything that you don't like
and even if you've liked a bunch of
stuff joe biden has done there will be
some people where in february biden does
something they don't like
they now disapprove and they're not
going back and then in march joe biden
does something different that another
little cohort doesn't like and now
they disapprove and they never go back
so the erosion
of approval throughout a presidency is
relatively
common um with donald trump
he actually left office with the lowest
approval of his presidency
i think it was 29 according to i think
it was gallup so that's relatively
atypical
um also atypical would be like for
example george w bush after 9 11 had
like 80 80 something percent approval
that was a unique
uh sort of uh circumstance that that
explained that so
it's not particularly concerning um
i think that there's a there is this
gets me back to
biden needs a major accomplishment this
calendar year
another major accomplishment the vaccine
rollout has been huge
now the problem is too many people don't
want the vaccine getting coveted
stimulus done within a couple of months
that was huge we're now in the second
part of the year we're in the third
quarter we're going to be in the fourth
quarter before you know it
biden has to get something else done if
it's the infrastructure deal
that could be useful that could actually
lead to a couple points of approval
increasing but i think that this is all
pointing to a very interesting 2022
cycle
uh also in support of democrats in 2022
it's also really important that joe
biden get something else done
and then we'll see what happens as far
as the approval rating is concerned but
so far
everything is pretty typical slight
erosion
of approval but it's time for joe to get
something else done
we've got a great bonus show for you
today don't miss it
sign up at joinpacman.com we'll have
farron cousins
for a few days and also jesse dollamore
for a few days replacing me on upcoming
shows i will then be back
it's going to be incredible please be
nice to them guys please be nice to them
i would appreciate that
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to
an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman